you're here
wait you're
well first of all i contacted more than
one person
secondly she came here as jean herself
not as the acting grandmaster
a gene you would never see even as an
honorary knight
what a surprise i heard about the holy
liar but i never suspect so
the sound of the holy liar can purify
storm terror and
that's right your honorary knight is
putting themselves on the front line to
try and resolve this storm terror issue
now that's the hot shot of the feels
like we're breaking the law though
i understand this kind of absurd
explanation is hard to believe
but we can ask the bard to play the song
again to try and persuade
i believe you to persuade our stubborn
command
wait what i can't think of any reason
for devolence betrayal
given it was once one of the four winds
however
if it was poisoned in the battle and
then corrupted by the abyss mage after
it woke up
but as acting grandmaster i obviously
cannot make such a statement diplomatic
pressure from the fatoui
makes it hard for us to seek a peaceful
resolution to the storm terror issue
people would think i've lost grip on the
gravity of the situation
that's why i can only do this in private
that's one of the reasons i don't like
what surprises me is that you would
believe an outlander so easily
my cautious and meticulous superior even
you trust him
don't you sir
i already told you not to call me sir
never mind we don't often get to work
together after all
uh wow i have a rough idea of where the
holy liar to hamel is
nice recovery she's really talented at
changing the subject
the conflict between monsta and schnez
stems from the conflict between the
seven nations and their respective god
the cryogod's fatoui seemed to be after
the animal god's power
right if the knights of fivonius
publicly prevented an attempt on
the only other way to affect that the
number of fatui that have come to
monster is far from limited
i've already managed to d luke has
determined that the holy liar is not
being held in the goth i imagine they
don't want to leave something stupid
gets it if too much of us such as
outlander ready